so we kind of went on like a one-hour
tangent from joey saying we're gonna get
back to explaining with the title of
this video
[Laughter]
holy [ __ ]
fashion joey's like we'll get back to
this we'll get back to this one
yeah so uh
we're gonna be leaving japan after this
episode for a little bit of time
specifically
two months
quite unquote is it two more and a half
months it doesn't really matter because
i mean you guys aren't going to know the
exact yeah yeah we're going to be
filming trash taste in um abroad yeah
we're going
yeah we're going is this we the next arc
is going to be trash tastes abroad
basically
we're going to say goodbye to this
studio for now uh because we're going to
be filming
in some of the different countries that
we're going to be in uh i mean obviously
one we can say because we announced it
like a couple of episodes ago yeah you
know since if you guys watched the
episode four episodes ago yeah i think
where we announced where we're going to
ax by the way see you guys there yeah uh
then obviously uh you'll know we're
gonna be in la for a while yep so uh
yeah we're filming some episodes in l.a
we're gonna be in london as well yeah
we're gonna be because these boys are
gonna be coming to the wedding as well
my wedding which by the time of release
of this episode should have just should
have happened should have already
happened yeah yeah yeah so congrats yeah
congratulations thank you if everything
goes
if you're watching
this this is uh yeah i'll be a married
man irl by the time this episode comes
out uh tyrell as opposed to the national
message as opposed to youtube
that's gonna be the altar and the guy's
like do you say i do godzilla
but yeah like uh so we're gonna be
filming some episodes in london some in
la um and we're gonna have like a lot
more guests on than we usually would for
trash taste there's gonna be like a lot
of guests yeah yeah it's gonna be like
an answer
so we had like no guests for like 20
episodes yeah yeah you have a lot of
guests in a row and obviously you know
some people are gonna like that some
people don't like it but i think we just
want to we want to go somewhere and mix
it up yeah yeah yeah yeah you know if
you don't like the episodes you don't
like we'll be back you know nothing's
going to change don't worry we haven't
we have over 100 episodes at this point
yeah yeah
anyway so uh you know it's something we
want to do we want to mix it up and uh
we hope that the change of scenery will
look interesting as well i mean
obviously won't maybe not look as
professional but yeah hopefully it'll uh
still be the same old podcast let's
press the fresh air yeah because because
like we've had we've had so many guests
that we've wanted to come on and
it's been like two years of just
constantly waiting and waiting
maybe it's gonna come maybe and then now
that we can fly out and maybe like we
are we are just basically it's the
floodgates just opening right and it's
just everyone coming on at once because
it's everyone that we've wanted to come
on and we've talked to before about
wanting to come on uh all coming on at
once so
we're excited uh and it's going to be a
lot of fun i hope yeah i think so a lot
of big episodes back-to-back i think
yeah yeah yeah and we're not just going
to be uh filming guest episodes we're
going to be filming some specials as
well
you're going to have your like your
first trash taste specials abroad as
well we're not going to
spoil what those specials are yeah but
uh yeah we should be good yeah yeah we
have we have a lot planned for trash
taste yeah in the coming months if you
miss just us i'm sure there'll be some
episodes sprinkled in there that are
just the three of us yeah yeah
definitely yeah i know there's a good uh
uh a vocal bunch on the suburbs love the
just us three episodes yeah yeah and i
guess they're so used to it now so yeah
it's such a it's such like an
interesting divide though right because
it's like you know
in my head it's like yeah the [ __ ]
guest episode's like awesome because
it's like a new person a new perspective
yeah new topics to talk about right but
then there are a lot of people who are
just like
oh like
they're looking forward to like who this
who is who does me okay i think we try
to make the guest episode so even if you
don't know the guest you can kind of
they can come on right yeah yeah i mean
we've had what three guest episodes
before this one right yeah so you know
our guest episodes aren't as personal so
i understand that people might not enjoy
them as much
if that's what they like most about
trash taste yeah yeah yeah because
obviously we can't go into a lot about
how we feel about things in our own life
because it's like we're trying to make
sure the vibe is good and the guest can
can vibe yeah yeah exactly well that's
why we decided to just have it the three
of us when we started right because
you're like if we put a fourth person in
there not a whole lot of like deep
conversations yeah
you know there's gonna be like two it's
gonna be two on this earth we're clowns
but we we some sometimes we uh wanna not
be clowns and just wanna chill and vibe
you know yeah
surviving bro just vibing
we're clowns but we all survived as
clowns as well
that's a clown vibe
[Laughter]
so i'm sure there'll be a fun fun
america stories while we're there oh
yeah and i'm sure i'll gain a lot of fun
uk stories as well yeah i'm sure
god i'm not looking forward to gaining
weight yeah i've been trying i've been
trying my [ __ ] hardest to not gain
weight before like obviously my wedding
as well yeah like it's it's really hard
whenever you travel out because
one of the hardest things is keeping to
a schedule right or keeping a habit and
like when you're living in the same
place and you like build this habit you
know you you can stay on this habit and
it's so much easier but when you when
there's like even like a slight change
in environment or something you know um
it's so easy for just like one domino to
fall over and like everything just falls
over oh yeah and you just like slip into
like the complete opposite lifestyle of
what you had
i'm trying my best to stay healthy right
now i've been like going to the gym like
every day yeah it's like working out
because i'm like i need i need to be
healthy before i go out there couldn't
be me
i just i don't know i also want to get
in shape as well so yeah i mean i feel
more energized when i've worked out yeah
yeah so i feel like i need that yeah i
cannot like the exercise bike every now
and then still at home because we bought
one quite a while ago so like whenever i
have time i do that but like
yeah i don't know like again like i was
going to the gym for a while and then
just that one trip out for like a week
just completely throws everything out
yeah yeah yeah and then you come back
and you're like
oh [ __ ] now i gotta start from the
scratch again you know yeah and you're
just like not motivated at all yeah and
that's just like it's just a complete
like habit killer well
i don't know i'm kind of picky like if
the because some hotels are like we have
a gym yeah and you rock up to this gym
and it is literally like a treadmill
from the 80s that like
it's just so [ __ ] yeah and you're like
well okay i mean i guess i'll do that
and they got like no weights or anything
yeah okay i mean all right i guess i'll
just run
and then you just like okay and then you
go to the next place and they're like we
have a gym oh gym's closed or something
like it's just like it's so hard to like
can stay consistent working out when
you're traveling
impossible i don't even try to pretend
to try and keep up i remember when i was
going to the gym crazy like when i lost
the majority of my weight like before i
came to japan i was doing it while i was
going to the conventions and it was so
[ __ ] hard yeah waking up in the
morning before a convention and going to
the gym oh my god it was so hard oh my
god i'm also bringing your gym gear with
you yeah it's pain in the ass just bring
your 75 dumbbells man
that's all you need right that's all you
need you don't realize right in your
suitcase shoes take up a lot of room oh
yeah
shoes are painless and then also shoes
get dirty so i want to kind of like
cover them
yeah just like painting the ass and
you're gonna bring gym clothes which
you're not gonna wear any other time
okay any other time like i remember
before when i used to travel i'd be like
i'd have to use like the weight limit to
its [ __ ] maximum right of course like
you'd have to pack as much as you can
and if you're if you don't then you
could squeeze in more there but now like
i want to pack as light as possible
right and like shoes are the most like
annoying things right because so
annoying that they're like because
they're light but they take up the most
space
what the thing is are they light some
sometimes shoes aren't light i mean if
you're packing like boots like yeah if
you're packing like [ __ ] doc martens
then yeah like i need like separate
luggage just like these [ __ ] doc
mountains because because like here's
the thing like do you normally pack
extra pairs of shoes with you
the everyday shoes yeah the nice shoes
yeah it depends where i'm going right
sometimes like if i'm going to like say
like a completely different like if i'm
going somewhere that's like really
summery and beachy then yeah you know
i'll take like a couple of like flip
flops flip flops
they aren't shoes but like you know if
i'm going somewhere and i know i need to
go to like a fancy dinner or something
then you know i'll bring some like dress
shoes yeah yeah that's and and they are
just like most fiddliest things try and
[ __ ] fit in your in your life but if
i just need like a pair of sneakers then
i'm just taking the one pair of sneakers
yeah yeah like how many jeans you bring
how many how many pairs of trousers do
you bring oh one pair of jeans yeah
because yeah one pair of jeans because
i'm just like for some reason it's it's
it's so weird i like them bringing like
10 t-shirts five hoodies or whatever and
i'm like do i need an extra pair of
jeans sometimes the answer is no you
asking people how much underwear they
brought for like a five day trip right
and i was just like i was shocked is it
not five yeah yeah well how much did you
bring to a five day trip how many pairs
of underwear okay like
like it's five minimum but sometimes i'm
like maybe i need that extra pair of
underwear maybe i'll [ __ ] myself maybe
i'll [ __ ] my it's not underwear it's
socks how many pairs of socks do you
bring i always bring extra socks wait
why because you know you might run into
an instance where like say wherever you
are is raining for instance right yeah
your socks get wet you don't want to
wear those wet socks for the rest of the
day okay but actually i'm doing my
underwear yeah i can kind of okay
underwear for me if it's a five-day trip
i'm bringing
max six
how much you guys bringing how are you
guys ringing
five day trip
six right yeah six socks no underwear
underwear how many people
yeah
like like for me the amount of socks the
amount of underwear you bring should be
equal
right yes yes yeah yeah yeah i don't
tell you your face was just like yeah
yeah yeah yeah
on this video people were like eight
nine ten eleven and then like three and
then
yeah obviously like one yeah i was like
whoa
but like
eight what is happening or you're
bringing eight pairs of under what has
happened on your trigger double up right
like i'm i'm sorry you like in like when
you're working out it's a different
story right because if you're planning
the workout i get it because i when i
work out yeah
i am running through socks and underwear
yeah yeah yeah yeah of course i'm i'm
not re-wearing that underwear yeah yeah
yeah it sucks because like [ __ ] i only
got half a day out of this underwear
yeah [ __ ] wash it yeah it kind of
sucks you know but like if you're if
you're just going on a trip why do you
need more than five pairs does it make
anything it also depends on the climate
because if you're going to like
especially like a southeast asian
country you are sweating through that
[ __ ] underwear man
you're taking like four shells a day
yeah yeah yeah the swamp ass man is just
like it's on another level you need you
need those extra pairs of underwear man
but like this is like in america
i think there's a single place in
america we need more than five pairs of
underwear i guess unless you're going on
like a five-day trip to like death
valley you know maybe i just think that
like you know whatever